yo what is up everybody it is prestige
I'm an Ouija here with another
Borderlands the pre-sequel video now
today is gonna be I think this is my
third video in a row where it's not
about the gameplay this is just some
random game for that I have so enjoy
that but let's get into what I want to
talk about and I want to talk about new
DLC and a patch since it's not all DLC
so there is a new DLC confirmed by too
gay for Borderlands the pre-sequel it is
called the hollow dome onslaught it is
an expansion and it is a multi wave
arena kind of like um I would say it
sounds at least sounds like a mix of
digits truck peak and moxxi's underdome
in terms of just the title of it the
hollow dome not like holographics and
stuff but it seems like it's going to be
a wave arena and I'm hoping it is going
to be better than um the was it the
shock drop slaughter pit stuff that we
got before with the for pre-order in it
the game early with that stuff was
pretty cool but this as a DLC also it's
ten dollars this a December DLC should
be a lot better and higher grade than
that not to say that was bad since but
that was a much smaller thing and should
be addressed as such now also although
ultimate vault hunter mode is coming to
this game that is going to be free you
do not need to pay for that if you have
the season pass to get if you don't the
season pass to get it if you never
bought anything other than just the base
game you'll get it which end it's going
to add another ten levels to bore lines
r is equal and you're going to be
telling the story to gauge and Axton
which are to return in vault hunters
from Borderlands 2 if you didn't play
the game and one thing that looks cool
uh is that in an article I read about
this because gage and Axton are not the
most patient vault hunters on pandora
that they only want the intense juicy
bits which might mean some of the story
might be left out so it might be a
little less drag dragging on with some
of the quest I don't know maybe it'll
have all of the quests like normal
ultimate vault hunter mode I don't
really know we're gonna see I believe it
comes out on these
number 16 yes it does come out in
December 16 so it's coming out in like
two ish weeks that's pretty cool and
yeah Oh another thing to note just kind
of stuff about this so the onslaught the
hollow dome onslaught is going to have a
bunch of returning notorious enemies so
that's going to be a lot of characters
like you will one time characters like
ones with names not just trash mobs just
uh going to be actually guys that names
and that drop specific legendaries so
this might be a way that will actually
get to form the legendaries which would
be a good fix for the problem that 2k
has had in this game which is not being
able to farm a lot of the people for
legendaries and so this might help fix
that for one I don't think it's too good
of a thing under that this is a DLC and
if it's a fix for that then it shouldn't
be under his DLC but that is all
speculation so I'm not going to go too
heavy into that and also um was it was
the second part what was the second
point I was gonna say I was totally
gonna say something oh yeah there are
new enemies it says that this article
that I'm reading about it says that
there are new enemies uh in the hollow
domes so if there are like new unique
enemies that might mean new legendaries
so it does say that there will be new
weapons class mods new heads and skins
so I'm really hoping that that means new
legendaries and new actually new
legendary is not just recycled ones from
Borderlands 2 and if that is so this
would be a big step in the right
direction for 2k and gearbox however it
seems that if all of our problems with
borland's r is equal they seem to a lot
a lot of the problems that we have
seemed to have potential solutions in
this dlc it kind of sucks that like if
that is that how it happens that would
be great but on the other side of the
coin it's going to kind of suck because
it's DLC and the game and if their
problems that the community has with the
game they shouldn't be addressed in DLC
they should be addressed in just
in patches in-game content so that you
don't have to pay to fix problems they
use in the game however some people
don't see them as problems so I digress
so that's gonna be basically it for the
video just letting you guys know that
the hollow dome hallo domme onslaught is
coming coming ultimate vault hunter mode
it is coming um and it maybe looks a
little different the new ultimate
ultimate vault hunter mode might be
exact same as we had in more lines to
I'm kind of hoping it's going to be a
little bit different and yeah that's
about it hope you guys have enjoyed this
video make sure you check out my other
boar lines the pre-sequel content if you
like this stuff and they do do a lot of
borderlands brazuca content and yeah
that's about it hope you guys enjoyed
and I'll see you all later peace app